what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and we have so much to
talk about today i am super excited san
diego comic con is right around the
corner and of course marvel studios has
officially confirmed that they are going
to be attending and are going to be at
hall h and we have a few details about
the panel and what we should look
forward to at hall h this year meanwhile
we also have some news about the
fantastic forecast and it looks like the
direction that it is going may not be
what the fans were exactly expecting and
maybe hoping for i personally think that
it could actually be a really good thing
but we'll dive into that in just a bit
also ryan gosling has recently talked
about the rumors that he has been cast
as the mcu's nova insiders state that he
has recently met with marvel studios
about a role that he is going to be
playing in the mcu but ryan gosling has
apparently denied these rumors but has
said that he does want to play a
specific superhero in the mcu the only
question is is he lying of course if he
is playing nova in the mcu he can't
exactly come out and say it but we'll
talk about that in just a bit let's dive
into what to expect from hall h because
i know fans are really really excited
for this now first of all fans weren't
really expecting marvel studios to be at
san diego comic con because of d23 and
disney plus day even though san diego
comic con is typically the huge event of
the year that's where they reveal all of
their big stuff all of their breaking
news their new shows their new movies
it's usually there in 2019 they revealed
the entirety of phase four so fans are
hoping for some big reveals here but
here is what the description about their
panel says and they actually have two
panels one is much shorter and one is
the hall h panel but for those of you
who are interested in marvel's animation
projects like marvel zombies what if and
the new x-men 97 animated series coming
out this is going to be of interest to
you it is on july 22nd from 11 45 a.m to
1 15 p.m and this is what it says
they'll be talking about marvel studios
head of streaming television and
animation brad winterbomb head of visual
development ryan meiner dean and special
guests dive into all things animation
with exclusive looks at x-men 97 marvel
zombies what if season 2 and more so we
are going to be getting an official look
and reveal at x-men 97 i know a lot of
fans including myself are really excited
for that animated project coming to
disney plus so great news on july 22nd
which is 10 days away we are going to be
getting our first look now of course
hall h is what everybody is really
looking forward to if they were going to
do any big reveal about the fantastic
four or the x-men or kang or doom or
galactus or anyone it is going to be at
hall h it is on july 23rd so 11 days
away and it is from 5 p.m to 6 p.m it
says marvel studios president and
producer kevin feige and special guests
provide an inside look at the ever
expanding marvel cinematic universe an
inside look that's really exciting but
here's something that i want you to keep
in mind disney plus day is coming up not
too long after this and they're going to
talk about all their disney plus shows
and i would prefer hall h to kind of
talk about the movies and not the disney
plush show since they're going to get a
whole day for the movies but also keep
in mind that rumors have it that marvel
studios is going to be revealing a lot
of stuff at d23 as well so i'm almost
thinking of this like a part one and a
part two and kind of like a part 1.5 for
disney plus day in the middle but part 1
hall h we get a lot of new information
from marvel studios there some big
reveals hopefully some trailers then we
get disney plus day where we get
information and new clips from disney
plus shows and then d23 where we get a
lot of other reveals hopefully now as
far as what we are expecting to see i am
expecting to see new footage or trailers
from upcoming projects like ant-man and
the wasp quantum mania and black panther
wakanda forever these are the next
projects coming out and we're getting to
the point to where we're almost due for
a black panther wakanda forever trailer
so if they do drop any type of footage
or a trailer i think it's most likely
going to be for wakanda forever since
that is the next movie that is upcoming
but like i said keep in mind ant-man and
the wasp quantomania is not too far
after black panther 2 so maybe they'll
give us both maybe they'll give us both
at hall h but maybe they'll give us one
at hull h and then the other at d23 now
the casting rumors for the fantastic
four have been going crazy and there
have been a lot of interesting rumors
out there from the fan castings like
john krasinski playing mr fantastic
which you know ended up happening and
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness to other fan castings like zac
efron playing the human torch and to
other major reports stating that jason
seagal has been cast as the thing ben
grimm and that he will be actually
appearing in the she-hulk series in the
final episodes of the she-hulk series
now this is just a rumor this is not
confirmed in any way but the reports
have been flying now there are some
reliable insiders that are typically
right about a lot of the reports that
they put out people like daniel rbk
accounts like my time to shine hello and
others out there and with casting it's
always really tricky because casting can
always change and sometimes
misinformation is spread on purpose but
sadly right now it appears that john
krasinski might not actually be playing
mr fantastic and his wife isn't going to
be playing the invisible woman and
neither will bryce dallas howard be
playing the invisible woman or directing
the movie as was reported a bit ago and
here's apparently why some insiders have
heard that marvel studios is actually
looking to cast a mr fantastic sue storm
ben graham and a human torch around 20
to 30 years old now keep in mind if
these reports are true they are castings
for people not characters they want the
actors to be 20 to 30 years old because
let's face it sometimes actors who are
in their late 20s play high school
students in movies that happens a lot
but here's the really really cool thing
about if this is actually true and they
are looking to cast actors in the age
range of 20 to 30 years old this means
we will be getting a origin story of the
fantastic four now in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness we did meet a
mr fantastic slash reed richards who was
already well established the
illuminati's headquarters was literally
in the baxter building mr fantastic was
using great technology to teleport
himself into the building which was
revealed to be doom technology or
inspired by it at least but then mr
fantastic goes on to tell wanda that he
has kids of his own in which she asked
if their mother is still alive and he
replied yes further confirming that this
is a much established mr fantastic in
the 838 universe which is fantastic pun
intended but we would like to see the
origin story wouldn't we i certainly
would and the fact that if this is true
they are casting between 20 to 30 years
old means that it is going to be a true
origin story for the fantastic four i
think it would be kind of weird to just
throw them in there already established
and even if they did that eventually
they would have to kind of tell us their
origin story anyway so might as well
start off with the origin marvel is
really good at this and this is what
they've been doing lately with their
disney plush shows taking their time to
introduce characters now of course the
fantastic four is not going to be a
disney plus show it's going to be a
movie but i do hope it is an origin
movie and this casting age range leads
us to believe that they are indeed going
to be doing an origin story but
unfortunately that would mean that john
krasinski would not play mr fantastic
now it was confirmed that it was kind of
fan fulfillment there kevin feige kind
of casted john krasinski as the
illuminati mr fantastic because he saw
all the fan castings about him so
unfortunately that might be the only
time we see krazynski as mr fantastic
but also according to new reports ryan
gosling might be joining the mcu there's
been a lot of reports stating that he
has been cast as nova and recently
daniel rpk stated that he has met with
marvel studios about a specific role now
in a recent interview with josh harowitz
from mtv ryan gosling said that the
rumors about him playing nova were not
true but he said that there is one
superhero that he does want to play in
the mcu and that is ghost writer now
ghost rider is an awesome character and
i'm sure any actor would love to play
ghost rider i just don't see it sorry
especially after seeing those barbie
photos of him i feel like ghost rider
needs to be a little bit more rugged but
hey he's a really diverse actor i'm sure
he could do it however we have to ask
ourselves is he lying because obviously
he can't just come out and say oh yeah
those rumors about me playing nova those
are true so just because he says he's
not doesn't mean that he actually is not
playing nova have we learned nothing
from spider-man no way home these actors
are under contracts they could not say
they are playing these characters even
if they wanted to but let me know your
thoughts about this do you think ryan
reynolds is playing nova and do you
think he could actually play a good
ghost writer let me know in the comments
down below and also let me know your
thoughts about the fantastic forecasting
and what you're most excited to hear or
see from hall h at san diego comic con
and disney's d23 don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof